this video is sponsored by brilliant so
by now you've probably heard these two
facts one the planet is warming up two
the warming is caused by a huge amount
of extra CO2 that's been added to the
atmosphere but a very reasonable
question to ask and it has come up in my
comments a lot is how do we know that we
humans are responsible for that extra
carbon and so that warming well let me
present to you three reasons Old Town
new town and flavor Town Old Town using
pencil and paper we can estimate how
much carbon dioxide we're putting to the
Atmosphere by first estimating how much
fuel meaning coal oil and gas we burn
every year and they're multiplying that
number by the amount of CO2 burning a
ton of each one of those types of fuels
produces this is an old calculation
first performed over a century ago by
Swedish chemist svante Arenas check out
my video on the history of global
warming for more about that this method
isn't very accurate as it doesn't
account for other sources of emissions
like industry and farming but it does
give us a first estimate that we are
putting tens of billions of tons of
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere every
year however tens of billions of tons is
nothing compared to the approximately
750 billion tons of CO2 added to the
atmosphere from natural sources every
year those 750 billion tons of carbon
added to the atmosphere every year are
however almost exactly balanced by the
amount of carbon that is sucked out of
the atmosphere by the land and by oceans
something we know because the
concentration of CO2 in the atmosphere
has barely changed over the past several
thousand years up until the last couple
of centuries so the tens of billions of
tons we estimate we're adding to the
atmosphere tip the balance of the
natural carbon cycle the buildup of
extra carbon is due to us but we can do
better than this new town as you may
also know carbon dioxide affects the
climate because it absorbs long
wavelengths of radiation meaning that
the more of it there is in the
atmosphere the less Long wavelength
radiation emitted by the Earth thermal
radiation reaches space with techno
analogies fante Arenas could only have
dreamed of a satellite can therefore
look down on Earth looking at specific
wavelengths and see dimming and
calculate how much CO2 there is in the
section of atmosphere between it and the
surface if that dimming increases then
the amount of CO2 in that section of
atmosphere must also have increased we
can work out how much bypass dimming we
observe and that is exactly what
satellites like the greenhouse gases
observing satellite and orbiting carbon
Observatory 2 do to produce near
real-time data sets of how carbon
dioxide levels change across the globe
with high resolution but we can go one
better and put the observations into a
weather prediction model but instead of
running it forwards in time to produce a
forecast we can run the model backwards
in time to produce a hind cast which can
show us where the extra CO2 originally
came from Combine that with emissions
reporting from countries and ground
measurements and you can create a data
set of where changes in atmosphere CO2
came from humans land ecosystems ocean
ecosystems or wildfires in this
visualization from NASA of cumulative
changes in atmospheric carbon over a
year they are color-coded the conclusion
the extra CO2 added to the atmosphere is
overwhelmingly coming from where humans
are burning fossil fuels not from
volcanoes which would show up clear as
day in these data sets as Point sources
and we simply don't see but this is
basically just an updated
technologically advanced version of the
calculation in Old Town the really cool
proof of our influence on the climate is
in flavor town you may remember that an
element is defined by the number of
protons in its nucleus carbon for
example has six protons in its nucleus
and most of the time it has six neutrons
in its nucleus as well but sometimes it
can have seven neutrons or even eight
neutrons in its nucleus we call these
different forms of carbon it's Isotopes
carbon 12 carbon 13 and carbon 14. named
after the number of things in their
nuclei we can think of them as being
like flavors of carbon in nature about
98.9 of carbon is carbon-12 with about
1.1 percent being carbon 13. less than a
billionth of a percent of carbon atoms
are carbon 14 a tiny fraction but one we
can definitely measure if Isotopes are
like flavors then an object made of
carbon contains a flavor mix almost
entirely carbon-12 but with a dash of
carbon 13 and just a tiny amount of
carbon 14. however that flavor mix or
the isotope percentages will vary
slightly depending on what object you're
looking at for example plant matter has
more carbon-12 in it because its lighter
isotope is more easily absorbed in
photosynthesis plant Mattis flavor mix
is a bit less spicy by contrast carbon
emissions from volcanoes contain more
carbon 13 due to carbon-12 being more
easily incorporated into Crystal
structures like rock below ground
leaving the carbon 13 in the gases that
get ejected from volcanoes the flavor
mix is spicier than usual carbon 14 is
the interesting one though because it's
radioactive and so it decays into other
elements over time as such the fraction
of carbon 14 in an organic object
decreases over time as the carbon 14
decays we can use this fact to actually
date organic objects like say wooden
artifacts what we call radiocarbon
dating okay so what's the atmosphere's
flavor mix approximately 99 of the
carbon in the atmosphere is carbon 12
and 1 carbon 13 with about a billionth
of a percent carbon 14 but that's not
the interesting thing the interesting
thing is that the flavor mix is changing
it's getting less spicy firstly the
atomic tests of the mid-20th century
caused a spike in radioactive carbon 14
which is still dying down but secondly
since the Industrial Revolution the
fraction of carbon 13 in the atmosphere
has decreased as did the fraction of
carbon 14 until we started detonating
nukes so what does that tell us well in
order to dilute the amount of carbon 13
and 14 in the atmosphere the extra
carbon that we know has been added must
have a higher percentage of carbon 12
than normal or equivalently a lower than
normal percentage of carbon 13 and 14.
the lack of carbon 13 tells us that it
can't be from volcanic sources and the
lack of carbon 14 tells us that it must
be from an organic source that is very
very old so old that its carbon 14
content has basically decayed to nothing
an organic source so old that it has
fossilized
like the coal and oil that we burn as
fossil fuels the remains of plant and
animal life hundreds of millions of
years ago whose remains we have been
burning and whose carbon we have been
adding to the atmosphere in huge
quantities since the Industrial
Revolution diluting the amount of carbon
13 and 14. the changing flavor mix or
more properly carbon isotope ratio in
the atmosphere is perhaps the strongest
proof that we humans are responsible for
the extra carbon that has been added to
the atmosphere and so the warming that
we are experiencing to use a word that
the ipcc uses very rarely the evidence
is unequivocal as is the fact that in
order to stop the planet getting even
hotter we need to stop burning fossil
fuels it's not simple but
it's that simple
did you know that in the next few years
solar will have more installed capacity
to generate electricity than any other
source finally overtaking coal and
capable of generating nearly a quarter
of all our electricity the 21st century
is going to be powered by solar and so
an understanding of it is going to be
essential fortunately there is a free
and easy way to do this an interactive
course on the fundamentals of solar
systems is just one of the hundreds of
courses available right now at
brilliant.org who have kindly sponsored
this video Simply put brilliant is the
best way to learn maths science and
computer science online there are
courses are built around interactivity
so introducing you to a new topic and
then testing your understanding by
getting you to immediately apply your
knowledge in a fun way in their course
on solar power for example you are
introduced to the concept of energy
levels in atoms and then immediately
tasked with applying that knowledge and
this is just one of thousands of lessons
with more added every month why not
check out their course on predicting
with probability or thinking in code
both essential skills in understanding
climate science and projections of how
our climate will change as I've said in
several previous videos I wish that
brilliant had been around when I was at
school having another resource that
would supplement my learning in the
classroom and give me opportunities to
test my understanding in a different way
would have been invaluable to try
everything brilliant has to offer free
for a full 30 days go to brilliant.org
Simon Clark Linked In the description
and the first 200 of you to do so will
get 20 off brilliant's annual premium
subscription which would make an
excellent present for a student in your
life that's brilliant.org Simon Clark
with thanks to brilliant for sponsoring
this video I've been continuing to be
well brilliant thank you for watching
this video which was an experiment as
you may have noticed I've started doing
vertical form content on YouTube shorts
and Instagram reels and I've actually
made two versions of this video the one
you've just watched and a vertical one
I'm curious to see which one is is going
to reach more people and do more good
follow me on socials link down there in
the description if you would like to see
the results in coming weeks also in the
description are the names of my lovely
patrons who support me at patreon.com
forward slash simonoxvis on the screen
right now are the names of my lovely
executive producer patrons if you would
like to help me make more bigger and
better content and get access to
exclusive behind the scenes Vlogs and
pick a video topic a month then please
do consider supporting me on patreon if
you enjoyed the video please do pop it a
like or better yet give it a share in
one of your group chats maybe if you'd
like something to watch next here are
some of my previous videos and that just
leads me to say thank you again for
watching I'll see you in the next one